une opposition s'opposant et une
majorité qui votent comme un seul homme
logique mais en fait surprenant hier
encore marie-guite dufay comptait ouvrir
à la concurrence le trafic ferroviaire
régional
la droite et le centre j'y étais
favorable mais ce matin la présidente
fait machine arrière
vous avez cédé présidente à
l'impressionnant pire encore vous avez
cédé à la pression de la france de plus
à dos de votre majorité
une reculade pour éviter l'explosion de
sa majorité
marie-guite dufay s'en défend elle
préfère parler d'un timing inapproprié
il faut travailler de façon plus
rationnelle plus sereine justement pour
que cette anticipation qui est
nécessaire pour le service public
elle se fasse dans les meilleures
conditions j'ai tiré les conclusions du
fait que le débat ne pouvait pas être
serein dans le contexte national et
social que l'on connaît aujourd'hui sur
nile gauche de la majorité après avoir
menacé de voter contre la convention on
se dit satisfait finie la fronde places
à l'unité
il fallait qu'on revoit notre copie
voilà ça a été entendue c'est
satisfaisant pour je pense pour tout le
monde personne ne perd la face dans
cette affaire nous avons une très bonne
convention une polémique qui a occulté
l'essentiel la convention 2,4 milliards
d'euros vont être investis sur huit ans
pour le transport régularité des lignes
maillage territorial les points positifs
saluée y compris par la droite et le
centre
il ya des choses qui sont positives et
des choses sur lesquelles vous dites
sont vigilants c'est pour ça que nous
avons demandé à ce que le texte soit
modifié par amendement pour que le
comité de pilotage puissent être ouverts
aussi à l'opposition et que nous ayons
donc un pouvoir d'évaluation de la mise
en place de la convention d'ici 2019
grâce à cette convention 37 points
supplémentaires vont être créés
je plaisante